hi Sandra Bruce on NASDAQ OMX and I'm in
charge of the listings business on
NASDAQ so what I specifically do to
invest in innovation and job creation is
I work a lot of companies that are
looking to access the capital markets so
that they can continue to invest and new
technologies and create the next great
Apple or Google or Microsoft these are
type companies that we see listed on
NASDAQ and tell about innovating and so
then one of the other things it's doing
at Nasdaq is to create a separate air
market called the bx venture market we
believe this tier market will be for
smaller companies that don't have access
to capital bill had access to new
capital and we can be the X venture
market will open up a new avenue for
smaller companies to access and tap tap
tap capital at an earlier stage which we
again with these company there are no
access to tableau when the capital
markets then that creates jobs because
they'll need to employees to continue
2022 that make all these doing a facial
at work so I look at examples like
Google and Apple and Facebook and
companies like that that are looking to
hire a lot of new employees around the
world and that does create like a job so
and as that grow about innovation and
we're just looking forward to bringing
many more companies here to the market
this year in Latin a great tech guy
Justin will see in 2011